um so all right so new music coming you  got a new single coming with two  features that you can't talk about  all right  who's on the song who's on the phone  give us one of the two fifty percent of  the features  slug man  foreign  okay  it's that song is done though so is the  other guy from the bay or LA  he from L.A oh  yeah  don't be trying to get scared okay don't  be trying to guess we know you gonna  guess right and I ain't and I'm alive  and say no that ain't him  g-eazy's on the record yeah my [ __ ]  G-Eazy man great guy easy man he uh as  soon as I came home you feel me tapped  in it and got me to come to the club I  saw that man nice all about me out that  was a good feeling that's my [ __ ] right  there good times man well it's good  genuine dude for solely we have to keep  you out oh no I'm Gonna Keep Me Out yeah  oh I ain't going back